wie kann es sein dass ein verurteilter
sexualverbrecher wieder vergewaltigen
kann wie kann es sein dass ein solcher
man sich nochmal ein neues opfer suchen
kann diese fragen müssen jetzt auf den
tisch deutschland hat eine neue
diskussion über sexualstraftäter grund
der traurige fall eileen 14 jahre alt
tod ihr killer
29 jahre alt ein bekannter
sexualstraftäter dessen erstes
sexualverbrechen mit 14 da hat er
versucht elfjährige zu missbrauchen
danach zehn jahre in der psychiatrie
dann raus frei und offenbar bereit für
sein nächstes opfer für aline wer hat in
diesem fall versagt
der teufel see in hessen ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel für spaziergänger ein
ruhiger see mitten in einem
naturschutzgebiet
und möglicher tatort eines grausamen
verbrechens bei dem leichnam den wir
hier in dem see gefunden haben handelt
es sich um
mehrere tage treibt die leiche der
14-jährigen eileen im wasser des teufels
e 300 kilometer von ihrem zuhause
entfernt
was ist geschehen wieso musste das junge
mädchen sterben donnerstag den 21 juli
verließ eileen hier in gottenheim gegen
18 uhr das haus ihrer eltern
sie wollte einen freund zu fuß einen
pulli vorbei bringen aber sie kam nie
wieder nach hause zurück um 16 uhr
verlässt aline ihr elternhaus in der
hauptstraße im knapp 3000 seelen ort
gottenheim der weg zu ihrem freund ist
kurz nur 200 meter trennen die beiden
voneinander eileen läuft die hauptstraße
entlang biegt in die bahnhofstraße ein
und klingelt im schul acker an der
haustür ihres freundes doch ihr freund
ist nicht zu hause eileen ist weg wir
können mittlerweile sagen
[Musik]
anhand der digitalen spuren das eileen
in einem fahrzeug
von gottenheim in richtung hessen
gefahren ist
wir können nicht sagen inwiefern sie
dort freiwillig mit vor wie sie ins
fahrzeug verbracht wurde das ist
momentan alles noch beim jetzigen frühen
stand der ermittlungen offen zehn tage
später finden die ermittler dann die
leiche des jungen mädchens im 300
kilometer entfernten teufelssee
nordöstlich von frankfurt am main wurde
eileen am teufelssee getötet oder
versuchte ihr mörder hier ihre leiche zu
verstecken unklar die arbeit der
rechtsmediziner gestaltet sich als
schwierig berlins körper trieb zu lange
im warmen wasser der dringend
tatverdächtige kein unbekannter der mann
der das mädchen getötet haben soll sitzt
schon in haft er soll ein vorbestrafter
sexualstraftäter seien im jahr 2007 hat
er versucht ein mädchen zu vergewaltigen
63 strafgesetzbuch in einem
psychiatrischen krankenhaus im
sogenannten maßregelvollzug
untergebracht nach seiner freilassung
steht alliance mutmaßlicher mörder fünf
jahre lang unter beobachtung im januar
wird diese aufgehoben nur sechs monate
später der grausame mord an aline das 14
jährige mädchen soll er über social
media kennengelernt haben alliance
mutmaßlicher mörder schweigt bisher zu
der grausamen tat
[Musik]
und bei mir jetzt rainer wendt chef der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft ich grüße
herzlicher wind wie können wir alliance
familie erklären das ist angeblich so
wichtig war diesen jungen mann nach zehn
jahren aus der psychiatrie zu entlassen
und dann irgendwie wieder in die
gesellschaft zu integrieren
unsere strafrecht sieht nicht vor auch
gefährliche menschen ihr leben lang
hinter gittern zu halten nach zehn
jahren die entlassung ist nicht
ungewöhnlich
danach die sogenannte führungsaufsicht
ist ein programm des landes hessen wie
in jedem anderen land auch nach der
föderalismusreform ist die zuständigkeit
dafür in die länder übertragen worden
das ist eigentlich ein vorbildliches
programm das muss man sagen auch in
bezug auf andere länder hat es schon
sehr frühzeitig hier eine
führungsaufsicht installiert die sich
sehen lassen kann aber es zeigt sich
dass es natürlich auch in einem solchen
system schutzlücken gibt der rechtsstaat
sieht man nicht vor dass menschen hinauf
ewigkeit hinter gittern sind auch dann
nicht wenn sie gefährlich sind dafür
gibt es ja diese instrumente der
führungsaufsicht dass das nach fünf
jahren ausgelaufen ist ist das ergebnis
einer sachlichen prüfung die dann
stattgefunden das ist auch der regelfall
dass das nach fünf jahren ausläuft wenn
die person dann nicht auffällig geworden
ist der rechtsstaat sitten und einmal
vor dass jemand der dann seine strafe
entweder verbüßt hat oder gar keine
straftaten mehr begehen dann in freiheit
tatsächlich lebt das heißt eine tat wie
diese muss man in kauf nehmen dann muss
man nicht in kauf nimmt das bessere ist
der feind des guten auch und gerade im
bereich der führungsaufsicht wird viel
darüber diskutiert ist die qualifikation
unserer gutachter ausreichend die
bewährungshelferin und bewährungshelfer
sagen immer wieder dass es zu wenig
personal in diesem bereich gibt da gibt
es immer noch qualität zu verbessern das
bessere ist da immer der feind des guten
aber man kann nicht sagen dass wir von
einem schlechten system reden müssen und
schon gar nicht muss man sich irgendwo
mit abfinden also täuscht der eindruck
dass wir zu viel auf die täter schauen
zu großzügig sind zu sehr versuchen
diese männer wieder zu integrieren und
zu wenig an potenzielle neue opfer
denken wenn jeder fünfte rückfällig wird
jede fünfte wird rückfällig und jeder
der rückfällig wird ist einer zu viel
aber der rechtsstaat siethen einmal vor
dass wir uns auch alle mühe geben müssen
tatsächlich mit diesen personen von
denen eine gefahr ausgeht fertig da
können wir uns herr wendt genügend mühe
die opfer die potenziellen opfer zu
schützen wenn jeder fünfte rückfällig
ausdrücklich nein da geben wir uns nicht
genügten das zeigen ja immer die vielen
beschwerden auch diejenigen die
beispielsweise im strafvollzug tätig
sind und dort über personal marie klagen
das heißt zu wenig mit den menschen
machen können die dort hinter gittern
sitzen aber die antwort des
rechtsstaates kann nicht sagen alle von
denen eine gefahr ausgeht und ihr leben
lang einzusperren so große haftanstalten
gibt es gar nicht und deshalb muss man
außerhalb der haftanstalten alle
bemühungen tatsächlich verstärken und da
sieht noch viel potenzial noch es ist
nur so schwer zu verstehen dass jemand
der mit 14 eine solche grausamen tat
zumindest erstmals versucht an einer
elfjährigen dass der nach zehn jahren
psychiatrie tatsächlich bereit ist sich
wieder ganz normal zu integrieren es
schwer zu verstehen ist umso umso
wichtiger ist es dass in diesem bereich
größerer anstrengung vollzogen werden
das heißt in einfach nur raus zu lassen
und zu beobachten ist das eine das ist
notwendig polizei bewährungshilfe alle
tun da ihr möglichstes aber es muss
natürlich intensiv mit diesen personen
auch sie müssen sehr engmaschig betreut
werden wenn das denn gelingen soll und
hier ist es offensichtlich nicht
gelungen aber es gelingt in den
allermeisten fällen auch das muss dazu
jetzt wird dieser mann eine neue strafe
bekommen und dann irgendwann wieder
freikommen das ist nicht sicher zunächst
einmal muss eben jetzt die tat
nachgewiesen werden vor den beamtinnen
und beamten von staatsanwaltschaft und
polizei liegt jetzt eine menge arbeit es
ist ein
ermittlungsergebnisse eine person ist
festgenommen dringend tatverdächtigen
untersuchungshaft es spricht vieles
dafür dass diese personen die tat
begangen hat verurteilt ist er noch
nicht und es spricht auch vieles dafür
dass wenn danach der ersten tag weil er
ganz offensichtlich psychisch krank war
und deshalb nicht verurteilt wurde
sondern einer psychiatrie untergebracht
wurde das auch jetzt wieder passiert
sagt ihr herz der man darf nie wieder
frei kommt eigentlich ja dann gab meiner
band danke an den chef der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft
und unser reporter hagen stegmüller ist
in gottenheim dem heimatort von eileen
in gottenheim hagen natürlich wut trauer
und sicherlich auch die frage wer hat
hier versagt
morgen vertriebs ja diese frage taucht
natürlich auch auf warum man muss ich es
sowieso vorstellen gottenheim ist ein
gesegneter ort bis vor einer woche gab
es hier wahrscheinlich nicht mal einen
diebstahl man hat hier einen blick auf
die vogesen der storch brütet noch auf
dem kirchturm darf man kennt sich von
vereinen die familie von eileen des hier
verwurzelt der vater wegen dem
gesangverein
eileen soll früher fußball gespielt
haben hat hier freunde gingen zur schule
und von heute auf morgen wurde diese
idylle zerstört und all das was eben
angesprochen wurde diese
fassungslosigkeit wut und trauer die ist
natürlich immens und wurde natürlich
auch dadurch noch einmal gesteigert dass
man gehört dass es sich um einen
vorbestraften
sexualstraftäter handelt und einfach die
frage ist immer wie kann das sein wie
darf das sein warum werden unsere kinder
nicht besser geschützt viele haben jetzt
auch selber angst um ihre kinder oder
enkel
es läuft aufs neue die diskussion
anlagen wegsperren für immer das ist ein
ganz besonderer fall ein junger mann der
mit 14 zum ersten mal so schwer
straffällig wird der im alter von 14
jahren seinen ersten missbrauch seine
erste sexualstraftat beginn bzw begehen
will ja wie welche antworten findet man
dort in gottenheim auf die frage
wegsperren für immer
man hat schon mehrere sachen ins spiel
gebracht zum einen natürlich das
klassische wegsperren wie kann einer so
war so jemand jemals wieder rauskommen
man diskutiert ja auch etwas über über
fußfesseln manche sagen
solche menschen müssen mit medikamenten
ruhig gestellt werden dass eben dieser
trieb der sich offenbar nicht weg
therapieren lässt dass der auf null
heruntergefahren wird sie wünschen sich
einfach antworten dass so etwas nie
wieder passiert aber unabhängig davon
allein ist natürlich tot und wir möchten
auch mal zeigen wie die menschen in
gottenheim trauern das rathaus sie hat
sich zu einer pilgerstätte entwickelt
seit sonntag am sonntag war auch schon
in der kirche oben ein gedenkort
eingerichtet hier kommen unablässig
menschen her und legen gedenkkerzen
nieder blumen es ist ein streng
katholische ort viele menschen
bekreuzigen sich davor sie fahren hier
mit dem auto weil es gibt keine dann
nicht den blick nach rechts dreht die
welt scheint in gottenheim für einen
moment still zu stehen
stegmüller aus gottenheim vielen
herzlichen dank für deine schilderungen
[Musik]
bild grieg news
breaking news ein tödlicher einsatz die
polizei hat einen mann in einem hotel in
berüchtigen frankfurter bahnhofsviertel
erschossen mitternacht wurde die polizei
zu diesem hotel hier in der moselstraße
gerufen was genau sich darin abspielte
das ist noch nicht bekannt gleis nur
spezialkräfte chancen bei dem einsatz
auf einen mann der später an seinen
schweren verletzungen starb
und vier nachts hat sich das ganze
abgespielt und die polizei die spricht
von einer bedrohungslage die dort
stattgefunden da muss man noch
nachreichen was darüber bekannt ist
unsere reporterin jessica verleih ist
genau dort im frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel 30 kannst du uns schon
ein bisschen genaueres zu dieser
bedrohungslage sagen also warum gab es
da diesen
spezialeinsatz der frankfurter polizei
dazu kann ich nichts sagen ist immer
noch das bekannt was bislang bekannt ist
man sieht hinter mir das hotel das lka
kommt er immer wieder raus spuren werden
gesichert woran es wirklich lage was
wirklich passiert ist weiß man nicht wie
viele schüsse abgefeuert wurden weiß man
auch noch nicht genau also momentan ist
da kein keine weiteren details bekannt
zu der tat oder was genau passiert ist
wie sehr die bedrohungslage eskaliert
und was genau passiert ist jessica wir
sehen im hintergrund da laufen die
ermittlungen um vier uhr morgens hat
sich das ganze abgespielt ja wie
verändert das auch die stimmung dort im
bahnhofsviertel ein viertel das jahr
weit über die grenzen von frankfurt aus
berühmt ist
also ganz ehrlich es verändert die
stimmung überhaupt gar nicht es ist so
ein bisschen schockierend wenn ich das
hier zusage aber das kommt mir so
langsam tobi daily business ich liebe
meine stadt wirklich aber das
bahnhofsviertel ist wirklich so ein
viertel wo ich sag ich fühle mich hier
nicht sicher als frau schon gar nicht es
ist das eingang zu unserer stadt es ist
eine katastrophe
diese die die komplette lage ist hier
einfach nicht im griff ich kann euch ja
schon mal so ein bisschen rum zeigen wie
das ja aus sieht man kommt ja langmann
wird angesprochen angepöbelt überall
sind irgendwie junkies die am boden
sitzen nickerchen machen auf
irgendwelchen ist an sich eine spritze
in die vene jagen hier ist alles
schmutzig hier ist alles dreckig es
stinkt unfassbar hier sind überall
glasscherben ich bin vorher einfach nur
diese straße hier entlang gelaufen da
kam eine wasserflasche aus glas vom
balkon aus runter geknallt und ein
passant hat fast getroffen und er
hattest du zurückgesprungen und wusste
gar nicht wie ihm geschieht hier kann
man auch kommt mir liegen überall müll
liegen menschen hier sind auch noch
handschuhe die auf dem boden liegen ich
weiß nicht wie gut man das sieht
wahrscheinlich von dem einsatz gestern
das weiß ich aber nicht sicher hier ist
auch etwas was aussieht wie ein
blutfleck da bin ich vor dem rennen
vorbei gelaufen fand ich sehr
schockierend hier sieht man auch noch
ein scherbenmeer team blickt etwas was
so aussieht wie ein blutiger verband
also das bahnhofsviertel ist wirklich
wirklich ein sorgenkind und
es klingt traurig aber es ist wie immer
ich glaube es überrascht keinen mehr
starke worte von unser bild reporterin
in frankfurt die sagt sie liebt ihre
stadt aber gleichzeitig angeekelt
angewidert und auch mit mit angst geht
sie in dieses frankfurter
bahnhofsviertel jazziger zeigt uns
nochmal dieses hotel ja man muss ja
sagen in anführungsstrichen hotel das
ist jetzt nicht gerade ja wahnsinnig
angesagt der absteige dort ich versuche
das bild ganz zudrehen weil wenn ich das
so halte ich hier das ist das hotel hier
steht das
auto vom lkh hier sind noch die ganzen
ermittler die die haben sich auch ganz
raus gehen das ist das musikhotel hier
keine ahnung wer da
und dazu kommen die fenster sind
geöffnet und den meisten fenster sind so
braune sehr schwere vorhänge davor es
stehen auch schuhe keine an und wägen
die gehören also es ist jetzt ja so
sieht hier aus aber so sehen wir schon
auch vor jedem hotel aus
bahnhofsviertel
schock in version schilder ist von
diesem viertel des scheint so ein
bisschen außer kontrolle geraten zu sein
was deine eindruck jetzt auch feste
machte in diesem fall aber auch mit
blick auf die vergangenen monate
vergangenen wochen hat die polizei
dieses viertel das ja wirklich im herzen
frankfurts liegt überhaupt noch im griff
ist ja für möglich
dass das ist das weiß man irgendwelche
mal hat es geschmeckt hat die ganze
situation noch ein bisschen schlimmer
gemacht auch wenn das blöd klingt die
bahn unter nacht wurde auch abgesagt
darum geht man auch dass das daran hängt
das wirklich hier ist viel schlimmer
geworden ist ich weiß ich hab euch in
hat letzte woche sehr oder zur 2 du
musst auf dem video aufgetaucht wo drei
männer beieinander standen und einfach
einem damit arme verschränkt vor den
stand und sich ganz normal mit ihm
unterhalten so dermaßen von ausgeknockt
wurde es war mit dem kopf so ja lass das
aber zeigen gerade jessica wir haben die
bilder nochmal vorliegen du sagst ist es
ist gerade knapp zwei wochen her hier
sehen sie die bilder nochmal also ihre
szenen dort aus dem bahnhofsviertel
sowie jessica das gerade geschildert hat
einer dieser männer wird er ausgeknockt
und dann wird einfach in die taschen
gegriffen hat wird der mann ausgenommen
ausgeharrt vorne sind sie eine frau die
mit einer decke vorbeiläuft für die das
offenbar völlig normales auch und andere
passanten laufen auch einfach vorbei das
ist da alltag offenbar der guckt man
nicht genauer hin ist froh dass man
damit nichts zu tun hat eine schlägerei
die dort ja tatsächlich alltag ist im
frankfurter bahnhofsviertel ein mann der
ausgeknockt wird dann liegen gelassen
wird hört doch den aufprall da vom kopf
und die menschen die drum rum laufen und
sich im grunde nicht groß drum scheren
das ist dort ja die schilder sich
jessica der alltag dort im viertel ja
ich weiß nicht wie in dem man den ton
auch wirklich hört ich habe das wirklich
tun gehört und diese auf schlag das
klagen wirklich als werden blumentopf
auf den boden gefallen und denn man ist
ja auch in der sekunde einfach nicht
mehr da nicht mehr bewusst weil er sich
ja nicht einmal versucht irgendwie
aufzufangen oder so und dann diese leute
sind da so
ich will nicht sagen ignorant weil ich
nicht mal wirklich den vorwerfen möchte
dass sie überhaupt noch sehen was da
passiert sind einfach blind geworden für
die komplette situation ist kommt mir
vor wie so ein eigenes eine eigene stadt
in der stadt vor eigene gesetze langsam
herrschen und ja man fragt sich so ein
bisschen wann tut mal jemand was und
dann tut man wirklich jemand was und wie
lange wird das dauern und was muss man
tun damit einfach besser wird ich werde
ganz kurz nachher ging ich glaube auch
hören weiß gar nicht was mit den mann
dann letztendlich passiert ist das aber
auch kein krankenhaus gelandet ist oder
ob es gut geht es auch noch so eine
sache keiner weiß hier irgendwas
live zugeschaltete aus frankfurt wo eine
mann von der polizei erschossen wurde in
dem hotel hinter ihr die
ermittlungsarbeiten wir sind noch im
vollen gange gleichzeitig schockierende
schilderungen über ein viertel der im
hintergrund sind die großen bank nicht
weit davon entfernt das bahnhofsviertel
in frankfurt ich das völlig außer
kontrolle zu sein scheint jessica danke
für deinen schilderung ja deine ganz
präzise
tötungsaktion mit einer ganz besonderen
waffe die wir uns hier in dieser sendung
einmal genauer anschauen wollen da ist
sie und julian rapp geht ist hier bei
uns im studio unserer militärexperte die
uns der uns diese ninja missal wie es
hier heißt genauer erklären kann denn
dieser rakete arbeitet nicht mit
sprengstoff sondern mit schwertern die
herausfahren dann abgesetzt von einer
drohne eine ganz besondere technik was
genau steckt da dahinter ja ganz genau
das ist also eine präzisionswaffe die
man eben nur einsetzen kann wenn man
ganz genau weiß wo ist das ziel beruf
befindet es sich um man eben ganz
präzises angreifen kann also da ist das
schon gesagt das ist eine eigentlich
eine klassische hellfire rakete die eben
von einer drohne einer in dem fall eine
reaper drohnen der usa abgefeuert wurde
die aber eben kein sprengstoff an bord
hat sondern bei ihrem einstieg im
messerscharfe klingen in alle richtungen
entfacht und dazu muss eben ganz genau
entstanden das können die usa das können
nur die usa das heißt man hat vielleicht
ein tötungsart 52 metern maximal 12
metern wo wirklich jeder der da ist der
wird auch getötet dazu muss allerdings
die krone auch auf 12 meter genau ist
hier treffen und das hat diese reaper
drohnen bzw auch denn diese hellfire
rakete die sind ninja rakete dann auch
getan das war einmal darauf schauen
julia auf diese spezielle waffe also die
diesen präzisions schlag jetzt dort
ausgelöst hat in kabul was sagt das auch
über die kenntnisse der usa jetzt in dem
land das sie ja quasi fluchtartig
verlassen haben vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr offenbar hat man noch recht gute
informationen dort in der hauptstadt
zumindest in kabul die usa haben das
land verlassen die us drohnen haben das
land nicht verlassen wir haben also
sichere informationen auch immer wieder
von fotos das permanent vier us drohnen
vier us drohnen über kabul schweben etwa
an 15.000 bis 20.000 meter sind also so
hoch dass wenn die taliban luftabwehr
hätten die könnten ja mit nicht
angreifen die usa wissen ganz genau auf
den meter genau was passiert dort in dem
land und sie können eben mit der technik
des crm mit der aktuellen technik die
wir nutzen können immer mehr können sie
aus diesen 50 kilometern gesicht
erkennen sie können genau sehen wer ist
wann auf welchen ball kommen und
offenbar wurde wie wir auch gehört haben
von den beiden über sechs monate genau
angeguckt wo ist der mann ist er draußen
man macht er seinen spaziergang und so
weiter und man hat dann gesagt jetzt
können wir diese drohne und diese waffe
einsetzen die eben seine familie nicht
gefährdet sondern nur ihn tötet
faszinierender präzision und
faszinierende waffe die den
al-kaida-chef jetzt getötet hat julian
röcke mit 1 hintergründen zu dieser
waffe vielen herzlichen dank für deinen
besuch
und auch an diesem dienstag krieg seit
fast einem halben jahr inzwischen
kriegsalltag und der sieht so aus sie
plündern sie vergewaltigen sie foltern
und sie sind auch noch stolz darauf in
grausamen bildern zeigen russische
truppen märz wie sie ukrainische
kriegsgefangene missbrauchen bevor sie
sie dann kaltblütig ermorden in diesem
internierungslager verbrennt russland 53
kriegsgefangene ein russischer soldat
schneidet einem ukrainer hier in dieser
brutalen szene die hoden ab danach
erschießt er in putins barbaren armee
sie filmt ihre eigenen kriegsverbrechen
prahlt mit vergewaltigung bei kollegen
und bei familie und der ukrainische
präsident der schwört sein land auf
vergeltung 1 gegen den wie er sagt
terrorstaat russland
ich hole mir ein foto pro jahr heute
möchte ich allen einwohnern von nico
lange für ihre unbeugsamkeit danken
dafür dass sie die stadt und die region
geschützt haben ich danke auch nicoles
charkiw ribery und der gesamten region
mehr profit offs den starken menschen
von sabrina und der region allen ukraine
der region char soll allen die die
außenbezirke von odessa und der region
verteidigen ich danke ihnen für ihren
mut strategisch gesehen hat russland
keine chance diesen krieg zu gewinnen
und es ist notwendig durch zu halten
damit der terrorstaat auch auf
taktischer ebene seine niederlage spüren
wir müssen im süden osten und überall
durchhalten wir müssen in der
verteidigung der diplomatie und der
politik durchhalten wir müssen unsere
einheit bewahren und zwar nicht nur bis
zum sieg sondern auch danach um alles
was die besatzer zerstört haben
qualitativ wieder herzustellen ich
glaube dass wir dieses alles schaffen
werden
[Musik]